así es es lo que han comentado que en
esta ocasión no es el fin llegar a la
frontera aunque no lo descartan por
supuesto muchos de ellos sin embargo
pues la misión es reclamar aquí incluso
acudir a la cámara de diputados al
senado en la república y a la secretaría
de gobernación para pues insistir en que
allá en tapachula han por
meses estas solicitudes y que incluso ha
habido casos en los que pretenden
cobrarles por papeles que a la media
hora resultan falsos esto pues habrá que
denunciarlo a investigarlo pero lo
cierto es que la comisión mexicana de
ayuda a refugiados ha tenido cifra
récord entre enero y septiembre ha
recibido más de 90 mil 300 solicitudes
de asilo lo que representa un 119 por
ciento más que todas las presentadas
durante 2020 que fueron alrededor de 41
mil es decir son cifras nunca antes
vistas en un contexto en el que
147 mil emigrantes han sido detectados
tan sólo entre enero y agosto que
también es una cifra que no tiene
precedente